first of all congratulations we haven't
seen you guys since you've been engaged
thank you
it has been an eventful week and i feel
like a lot of fans are dying to know
what conversation did you have a ramona
singer actually kind of expose all that
wedding info
i called her and i'm like can you please
take that down off your story right now
she's like oh my god what did i do i'm
like and she's like it was the most
beautifulest invitation i've ever gotten
and i get a lot of invitations you know
how she is she didn't realize this
honestly yeah i think it was an honest
mistake did you freak out a little bit
yes
just because now i'm gonna have i'm
gonna have to have extra security yes
the date didn't change or not i don't
know we'll see i know we're up there
like some people you know they were
saying that like some people were
telling us we should do that so i just
kept thinking classic ramona i was like
yeah yeah i heard she even put her bank
account on on twitter once and i'm like
what
she does
yeah now is she still invited
yes okay yes yes yes how is wedding
planning going are you two kind of in it
together are you letting her kind of
call the shots uh very much in it
together yes i love that opinion yes and
i love his taste yeah i do yeah uh you
know obviously i we saw that margaret is
also invited is that a good sign or is
that a sign that you guys are in a good
place right now maybe okay like why you
know she's not the invitation i mean on
the um list what do you think yeah so
probably right i mean obviously you went
through it this season with the gals too
um have you guys settled it between you
and margaret are you guys in a good
target's a good person yeah very good
person
so after all these years you're still on
the show you're here at the mtv awards
what does it feel like to i don't know
be the og but also feel so much love
right yeah now i love it it's like it's
an amazing feeling it feels really
surreal
so you know i'm honored to be here do
you have any other housewives in your
wedding party ex-housewife dina manza
yes uh carolyn manzo is she invited no
no okay yes so you're like having it
your way and you know exactly how you
want it don't you second time around
that's how it goes yes
i'm gonna say what's the biggest lesson
you're going into this marriage
um just i mean we love patients yeah we
love and respect each other and honor
each other and you know that's the best
thing you know
that we you know we go we go by
yeah and communication like we have the
best communication which is really
important i think it also helps when you
have a ride or die and you two really go
for each other thank you
you